and so the way that differentiation is
not embedded in people's biology but
produced by the systems people live in
and I think that then calls upon us to
consider what is justice and the social
contract rather than assuming it's
natural that some people are living in
harm's way
that's what are the responsibilities of
societies when you've got this massive
unevenness in the possibility of health
and well-being and I'll again return to
it's even harder than we thought and so
you pointed to the intergenerational
responsibilities and now environmental
health research makes it very clear that
your exposures can affect more than one
generation and what does it mean to be
just to those how do the courts respond
to a kind of third generation effects
and part of that is because the newest
environmental health research sheds
light on endocrine disruption and
disruption of the hormone system which
implicates the reproductive system and
so just the intergenerational cascade of
effects we now understand a lot better
than we used to and then we say well
what are the legal and social responses
to that thinking about how our system of
justice itself reproduces the lack of
accountability that produced the
injustice in the first place and more
and there's more and more health
outcomes that are connected to
environmental exposures than we knew
even a decade ago diabetes for example
which was long treated as like a dietary
disease in genetic is now they're
connecting to plastics exposure and so
once you start recognizing the
environmental determinants of disease it
just complicates health care health
diagnosis insurance you know the whole
thing shakes up I think it's a lot
harder for people that are make their
living kind of in the belly of the beast
they it's harder to find opportunities
to do good works I
the most beautiful thing is people
having the capacity to collectively
evaluate what's going on and to imagine
and plan together for increasing and
equitably distributed prosperity so it's
not so much that I can imagine on a
world that's otherwise but perhaps it's
the teacher in me I can imagine us doing
a better job trying to architecture that
world as you've said I love that
architecting equitably distributed
prosperity I love that let's do it that
was beautiful someone's opinion may
contradict yours where's my friend Alan
it's all about your perspective who are
we in what is the nature of this reality
[Music]
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Satya we're on site at
the ant American Anthropological
Association Annual Meeting
for our second partnership with them
we're on site in Vancouver Canada doing
it we are now going to be talking about
the anthropology of environmental health
and much more we have dr. Kim Fortune
joining us on the show hi Kim
thanks for coming on the program thanks
for having me I'm excited to talk about
this with you let's start like big
picture understanding what is this is
this like humans and the way humans are
in our environments whether it be in the
most primordial environments among trees
and beaches and in Metropolis
amongst the craziness is of the tension
environmental disasters teach us about
about this environmental anthropology
has grown and diversified greatly in the
last couple of decades there was a time
when it was mostly a study of how people
develop ways of living with specific
environments what their food system what
food practices were how they made use of
and manage natural resources I came into
the field in the early 90s when
anthropology was shifting into the study
of complex and urban environments even
industrial environments so the kind of
environmental anthropology I do starts
at the fenceline of chemical plants when
they're sometimes blowing up always
routinely polluting the communities that
are nearby and so the environmental
injustice movement or environmental
justice movement emerged in that same
period in the US and around the world so
communities organizing themselves to
make sense of local pollution respond to
it
and so my research is focused on
communities exposed to industrial
environmental pollution how they've
responded
the courts have responded and
importantly how scientists have
responded and so how science has
developed to try and understand the
problem how science has changed legal
decisions affected the community's
ability to mobilize to improve
conditions in their communities and so
there's a lot of moving parts to it and
that's certainly just one thread of work
in environmental anthropology writ large
but one of the key questions is how is
environmental health unequally
distributed across social groups and so
how is it's a key site for the
production of inequality which is a
long-running
social question that anthropologists of
folks know many things come back to so
it seems as though then throughout time
we have moved from these like immediate
return hunter-gather style living to the
agricultural era to now the metropolis
era and now in the metropolis era
correct me if I'm wrong the poorest
people usually take on the biggest
amount of the environmental hazards that
we live with the most polluted air the
most polluted water the most polluted
environment around them most closest to
the landfills this type of stuff is this
about yes I mean this is the focus of my
work and of many anthropologists now
what's interestingly though is that
we're now realized that rural spaces are
also often hyper contaminated because of
agricultural pesticide use industries in
the countryside land runoff etc and so
the the sense that the urban the rural
environments are pure in the urban
environments art I mean that's gotten
more complicated and so there is a and
the traffic between industrial and rural
spaces of is of course part of a freight
traffic for example that moves
agricultural Goods into ports and cities
you know so it is a system of global
circuits that produces and spreads
pollution
but it is your you're absolutely right
it's a not new but it's a form of
anthropology that shifted the field away
from the traditional society focus which
was the its signature for much of the
20th century it does seem like it really
is really close in in my heart this
symbiosis that humans are with their
interconnectedness to not only each
other but their natural environment that
they're around and that environmental
anthropology from that angle being like
how did the humans actually engage with
their environment that they're in
is very beautiful and it feels a natural
but then there's something strange about
when you move humans to these metropolis
is stacked up in these boxes and then
having this whole process of like just
there's conspicuous consumption
happening there's a bunch of mental
health issues happening we're
disconnected from each other and from
nature there's so much that's happening
there's millions of people living in
such close proximity to each other I
mean they're just in equality like we
were just talking about there's so many
variables that are being crunched into
metropolis is even studying the
environmental anthropology of what it's
like to be trapped in like a whatever a
200 square meter box for a majority of
your time and like never hearing the
sound of birds and only hearing buses
and how that affects your neurology and
physiology I mean there's just how do
you figure out how to compute the
environmental anthropological variables
that actually affect our lives well the
the panel that I was just part of was
focused on the importance of much more
intensified interdisciplinary and
collaborative research because there are
lots of variables some of them we can
get at as anthropologists focused on
cultural dynamics we primarily use
qualitative methods but that can
powerfully supplement the kinds of data
collected in other fields but for the
for the most part we're not yet really
bringing those
analyses together but you're right to
understand both what health is and if
you understand health is determined as
much by social environment is
biophysical environment there's a lot of
variables and it's of course shaped by
what people think their health is what
news waves are telling them what their
health is what pharmaceuticals can you
know research how it affects government
regulation you know it all is a tangle
and so understanding both what's going
on what what's what's good governance of
that phenomena and I would argue that
the governing structures that we have
set up now where a department of health
is separate from the Department of
Environment which is separate from the
Department of Transportation and from
the Department of Education there's
functional reasons those are separated
out but certainly that what many people
call the silo effect has undercut our
ability to do to understand
environmental health and that's one
among many things anthropologists look
at is what is the social formation by
which we try and understand our own
problems yeah yeah this is this is
really interesting that this show is
super multidisciplinary show and so for
you to also be seeing data silos and how
to eliminate the walls and how to make
it so that the data points can actually
have pattern analysis happen across all
of them to find unique insights I love
that we talk about that a lot on the
program and so then is that then one of
you know one of there's a you know
solutions for understanding the multi
variability and the data points better
than their solutions for just the
environmental justice in general like
why is it that the poorest people have
to have the poorest the most health
hazards and the poorest health outcomes
from the inequality that happens with
environmental justice I mean you just
look at all of the different slums
around the world and it's just beyond
comprehension shantytowns people just
not being able to have adequate health
and also therefore adequate
actualization like people bringing their
best selves into the world their unique
gifts into the world and a social fabric
that's conducive for that it just feels
like sometimes that multi millionaires
and billionaires I'd find themselves at
these at the tops of these condos and
and out in the suburbs and mansions and
then poor people are stuck in shanty
towns and so how to actually deal with
making a fabric that's most conducive to
the flowering of consciousness in
general is a very complicated equation
as well so there's like that plus all
this data so we yeah give us these like
focuses oh I think so one kind of answer
is to say I think that we need a deep
historical consciousness to really
understand why are certain communities
predictably living in hazards way and
often it goes back to you know its land
use laws a century ago that made it
impossible for certain groups to live in
certain parts of a city for example or
access loans so that they could purchase
homes in a certain part of the city and
so the weighing legacy systems affect
where people are today because it's
amazing how often I you get the sense
that instead of compassion or since a
political outrage it's like well why
don't those people move where they can't
move because poverty produces poverty
and so the way that in the United States
for example you have African American
and Latin X communities most affected by
environmental risk both catastrophic
vast risk and slow risk and you say well
why well it's not only it's the question
of why they lived though in those places
in the first place and then when
generation after generation they live in
those places they
they have different bodies they have
different health outcomes and so the way
that differentiation is not embedded in
people's biology but produced by the
systems people live in and I think that
then calls upon us to consider what is
justice and the social contract rather
than assuming it's natural that some
people are living in harm's way
that's what are the responsibilities of
societies when you've got this massive
unevenness in the possibility of health
and well-being yeah this is an excellent
way to put it that as though in our most
naked form that we are we are we are
supposed to have a path to bring our
greatest gifts into the world but there
are cultural pressures that make it so
that rather than being born into a
social fabric that enables it it makes
it so that we're born into a social
fabric that makes it even more and more
difficult to achieve that actualization
or to bring these unique potentials out
into the world and so then what what
then is it that is it then like a
galvanization of efforts on on the scale
of governments or private companies or
of resource allocation nonprofits what
is it that can then make it so that
poverty no longer breeds poverty but
that there's avid environmental justice
efforts that can happen towards people
bringing their gifts forth well some of
it is saying no telling industrial
corporations that they can't cite and
add to the burden in particular
communities and it's repeatedly
communities that are have compound
disadvantage they already have very high
pollution levels and yet of facility is
permitted to come in and add to it and
there's just been recent coverage by the
Guardian of in Louisiana between New
Orleans
in Baton Rouge which is a string of
chemical facilities and I don't quite
understand why but there's all these new
facilities coming in and so and this is
literally the belt where the chemical
plants are built on the foundations of
the old plantation economies and so you
can literally see the reproduction of
injustice and so questions of should you
disallow companies from citing bate
because there's historic injustice in a
region that would be a new question for
governance that we've barely taken on
but to complicate it even further many
of the regions that are most affected by
the kinds of things I study industrial
facilities are also at great risk
because of climate deregulation so
Houston for example one of the cities I
study has now catastrophic rain events
that affect the chemical plants because
they lose power their cooling systems go
down they start you know emitting both
routine sometimes they catch on fire and
so the way that if we thought we had a
government's problem before we now
really have a problem because you've got
risk compounding risk compounding
historic disadvantage so it really is a
pot at a boil a perfect storm however
you want to think about it and we have a
lot of science telling us that the
problem exists that it's unevenly
distributed we didn't need to do a lot
more research to understand it well but
I think the bigger challenge is not the
science but actually being creative
about how we govern ourselves where
these inequalities and in Justices
aren't exacerbated as we deal with
changing changes brought by something
like climate change there you give this
solution of doing something to prevent
the further exacerbation of Justices
this is this is a this is crucial
another way seems as though that there's
the grassroots efforts and in grassroots
efforts to prevent the further injustice
from happening there's also just
awakening in general that happens
that can be catalyzed I mean this is
something we talk about a lot on the
program is that the more that people
awaken to the nature of this reality the
more that they are less likely to do
injustice upon others and does that
resonate with you this idea that we are
all one
well it certainly it resonates with me
and the teacher in me where I think that
one of the my goals as a university
teacher is just to make sure that these
very very rich stories are in people's
imaginations because I think a lot of
the injustice is we're talking about
people don't know about they don't we
are a standard educational approach
doesn't get at the multiple drivers of
this kind of reproduced injustice and so
I think these there's their sad stories
but stories that are good to think with
about why systems fail about what makes
a community what gives a community
well-being and there's going to be hard
choices and out just an example if
you've got a community in a high-risk
zone either because of industrial
facility or increased risk of flooding
and they're tied to that they've lived
there for generations but they're at
increasing risk so are they asked to
move are they told to move are they
moved as a community are they moved as
individuals do you need the whole
community to agree to to make the move
and all of these questions are happening
at sites around the world now and we we
are really fumbling in the dark because
we've generally leaned towards saying
you know people have a right to stay in
place that's been the progressive
position and it's there's many reasons
for that dislocated people usually it's
compounded harm on the other hand when
use what is the governance
responsibility when people we know that
people it's not a 500 year storm but a
three year cycle of extreme weather
events for example so really the kind of
way we've thought about even tree
people right and taking good care of
communities a lot of our paradigms are
really exhausted and we're going to need
people from with a lot of different sets
of eyes and skill sets across
disciplines across generation across
social classes and groups to come
together to imagine any different way to
do things and I think anthropology is a
key resource in part because it's it's
the founding of the discipline values
variation in thought and sees variation
in thought is a social resource and not
as a problem and so I think it that's
one part of imagining otherwise and
building a different society that
anthropology can help with see this big
picture ideas that we have as we've
moved into different circumstances of
living and birthing children into the
world that there has been environmental
justices that have changed over time
where it's like there's a certain amount
of potential for a child to bring
themselves fully into the world given a
certain birthing context and giving it a
completely different one we can label
that as an injustice that the social
fabric is not conducive to that child's
actualization whether it be some sort of
of a problem with their own like like a
public health issue in that region
whether it be just any sort of
environmental health concern regarding I
like this idea just this ability like
anthropological like gift actualization
so you we want the social fabric to be
able to unleash people's gifts uniquely
into the world as optimally as possible
and design around that and eliminate as
much of the environmental and justices
as possible and make it as conducive
towards
the actual ice processes and I'll again
return to it's even harder than we
thought
and so you pointed to the
intergenerational responsibilities and
now environmental health research makes
very clear that your exposures can
affect more than one generation and what
does it mean to be just to those how do
the courts respond to a kind of third
generation effects and part of that is
because the newest environmental health
research sheds light on endocrine
disruption and disruption of the hormone
system which implicates the reproductive
system and so just the intergenerational
cascade of effects we now understand a
lot better than we used to and then we
say well what are the legal and social
responses to that how did the endocrine
system get implicated certain chemicals
disrupt the way the endocrine system
works and some of the research knows
that an incredibly fine level of detail
like if if a fetus is exposed in a
couple of days and in the tenth week
then there's likely to be certain kind
of cascading effects and so the idea
that even before a child is born that
that you've got environmental health
effects but it even goes farther behind
that the panel I was on this morning one
of the researchers spoke about the
crisis or perceived crisis in fertility
rates and pointed to about what they
think is about at ten percent of couples
in China dealing with infertility and so
it's you know it's also the the
conditions in which people even have a
choice about having children based on
what is implicating the endocrine system
well so in when you've got really acute
exposures like in factories there's a
very clear connection between exposures
and fertility
so what chemicals do we know a whole lot
of them suite
yeah of things yep
the one of the chemicals that's gotten
or a chemical class that's gotten a lot
of contention is BPA's which is
absolutely ubiquitous it's in the lining
of cans it's in plastic bottles it's in
receipts you know the kind of coating on
receipts in taste something that's that
does not taste like water when you drink
water that has been in a plastic bottle
that's like in the Sun or it's been in
the bottle for like six months or a year
before you drink it like you can taste
something that's not just water like
it's taste like it's absorbed some of
the plastic and if you think about it
we've done at best mediocre job
regulating hazardous chemicals that come
from what the regulatory regime cause a
point source a factory emits a certain
pollution what you're talking about is
ubiquitous everywhere
creeping under the doorstep but but to
be fair I mean this was the focus of
Rachel Carson's would work and the her
book Silent Spring which was published
in 1962 so it's not entirely new
knowledge for sure I think really we
haven't developed a governing response
to it so it's like as we've
industrialized many of many people have
had issues with working inside of
factories and having exposure to certain
classes of chemicals but then also
there's just on a mass population scale
those that have progressed to let's say
just advancing the countries into
whatever first world countries that
they're exposed to BPA and other forms
of exposure to and your endocrine
implication system implication that then
cost things like infertility this is all
very interesting because there's so many
downstream effects that it's hard to
measure longitudinally over like 50
years what it what it does I mean we
were just talking about this earlier
this episode just people being jammed
into little boxes on top of each other
in Metropolis is well
when you don't get that much natural
light when you're not getting that much
exposure to fresh air when you're not
getting that much exercise you're not
getting enough sleep because there's
just economic machinery pressuring you
all the time you're far away from your
family you're far away from raising
children all this type of stuff
there's many downstream implications
that happen including the onset of
cancer and cardiovascular disease and
Alzheimer's and all these other things
that are very difficult to men to
measure this the intricacy of the
nuanced multi variability yet it's quite
physiologically evident on a
moment-to-moment basis you know when you
actually feel like you're divinely at
your peak state of performance versus
feels like meat inhaling the cars
exhaust on the street in a breath of air
feels like it actually sheds minutes off
of downstream my life versus indigeneity
people that are still living in complete
symbiosis with nature
they have just a much more cohesive
understanding of the interconnectedness
of everything plus their like their
environmental anthropological awareness
level must be like a 90 on a scale of
zero to a hundred and ours and
metropolis feels like it's 20 or 30 it's
disastrous it feels disastrous there
certainly is a what some people have
called a cultural disconnect where
people in urban environments don't know
where their food comes from don't know
where their power their electric power
comes from don't know where their waste
goes and the kind of systems thinking
that is needed you can see how it's been
structurally undercut by the way we've
organized our governments and organized
our educational curriculum for example
but it's also beyond what any individual
could make sense of on
so it's not a matter of getting rid of
the silos because we certainly need
people that specialize in transportation
infrastructure or you know cell biology
or so it's a it's a challenge of
thinking about the whole but also really
learning to leverage very diverse forms
of expertise in concert and I think it's
the in concert that is really the kind
of next generation of challenge and
there's a lot of things working against
that things the the rush to kind of make
knowledge proprietary put it behind
paywalls even among academics there is a
you know there's an enormous pressure to
kind of demonstrate individual
accomplishment that works against very
widely acknowledged need to work across
disciplines with the communities that we
study and so there is a change in the
way we approach knowledge production a
changing the way we use knowledge one of
my own current projects is focused on
how cities around the world we're
working in about 12 cities are trying to
understand their air pollution problem
building monitors outfitting citizens
with monitors what all they're doing and
then how they're trying to move that
knowledge into the governing system
great yeah that visualization component
is so crucial for them to see their air
pollution levels yeah and you know and
in some places the structure of city
governance and its history makes a
difference in kind of how things move
and you easily see that some places are
more data rich than others there also
can be a real investment in data almost
as a diversion get more data get more
data and it distracts from actually
doing anything with it so you know data
is not always a solution but trying to
and again understanding variation none
of the cities we look at because we look
we have five cities in India in the US
we've looked at Beijing none of them get
it right entirely but by understanding
comparatively you have a better sense
of what are the variables what are the
moments of opportunity or intervention I
mean I think that's again what
anthropologists are strong we can make a
strong contribution bringing that
comparative knowledge into the mix of
trying to imagine both what's going on
in the world in a different way of
organizing it yeah there's two points
there that are so big the first one is
when you push the edge of knowledge are
you trying to immediately create
intellectual property and hold on to it
yourself to try and profiteer on it or
reshape rules and regulations or are you
trying to democratize you like make a
tool then democratize it to the world
and let hundreds of thousands of
scientists continue pushing the edge
with it which actually enables
eradication of suffering at
unprecedented rates plus expansion of
human potential faster as well and I
mean that's becoming very clear and then
this other point that you brought up was
if you do things like take something as
complex as the air pollution and
visualize it or if you take something as
complex as inequality and also begin to
visualize it make it so that like like
rich like rich people can't just silo
themselves off and try and escape off to
us and the next celestial bodies but
rather have to actually focus on on
solving the SDGs and solving the most
complex issues that that literally
disrupt the lives of the people that
make us than two dollars and 50 cents a
day on a normal basis around the planet
because their health and wellness I mean
at the end of the day do you we want a
revolution to happen do we want rampant
inequality to continue the answer is
absolutely not and but the solutions
that have to come into place are ones
that require us to do things like
visualize the problems implement the
solutions and then to do things like you
know just on a global level just how can
we can how can we collaborate better
around these biggest pressing challenges
I mean you gave this example about
chemical plant disasters you give this
example about asthma rates I mean
like when we have this phrasing in B
it's not in my backyard so I don't give
a [ __ ] about it I mean that's literally
the worst frame of mind to have you are
not separate from other people this is
all one planetary organism that we're
all a part of and to understand that
when someone suffers it doesn't actually
increase the PI in your directional
favor it actually makes it worse
you these are your brothers and sisters
across the planet that it's our
collective responsibility to make it so
that they can bring their unique gifts
into the world and unleash them like
that seems like the root problem would
you say that like one of the root
problems of our issues that we have like
the most you know the most upstream
problem of what we face is our tendency
to feel separate from each other and
separate from nature rather than
interconnected that's certainly a root
problem and I think that a global
capitalist economic system not only
engenders that kind of sense of separate
success but rewards and encourages it
and so the question of how do we create
economic prosperity through a different
system that wouldn't you know at at the
outset presume that or have inequality
as a routinized
something that's produced by the system
it's just like you can know a factory
emits routine everyday of pollutants a
system a capitalist system produces
inequality as like something you know
just something the system does and so I
think we're going to have to go back to
really basic questions about how we
organize the production of our societies
what the kind of ends are and I think
that not all people are going to be
persuaded by the empirical documentation
of injustice or inequality because
that's a question for societal
deliberation and so again I mean how do
we what do you do if
you're at the table so to speak with
people who have naturalized inequality
as you know kind of part of the nature
of things and I think this is we need a
system that allows us to kind of work
through that and certainly empirically
you can say that have you know everybody
starts social that no one that everyone
depends on the social fabric to be what
they are even if they're the wealthiest
people in the world and so there is a
way that we can bring analysis into the
equation but there is just greed and
just political persuasion over system so
that people maintain control is an
intransigent problem that we that I
would argue is getting worse not easier
to deal with this may be the greatest
issue of our time is figuring out how to
catalyze feelings of interconnectedness
of of unconditional love of deep
presence with each other that being this
most upstream root issue would solve all
of the downstream symptoms that
sometimes we just go in like target
solving symptoms yeah and you know one
example of that from my research that is
useful to think about is we pay a lot of
attention to catastrophic disasters
people in acute need after a flood or a
storm or an earthquake and I think that
it's easy to think of it as that's one
those are exceptional events not normal
events and they can distract attention
from the everyday structural violence
that happens because people don't ask
for access to clean water or to a
healthy food supply or two avenues of
governance where they can change their
own situation and so the we need to be
careful than that in attention to
suffering that it's not
it's not seen as exceptional it's not in
disasters a funny word I tend to insist
that disaster can be fast and slow
because you can have disasters that are
not on the surface they're very quiet
like this one this is a slow disaster
yeah that's for me and I and disaster
can be distracting because people think
disasters kind of end it's like you know
when the fire fire trucks go home it's
over but just you know what does it mean
to remain responsible for a disaster in
the really long term because disasters I
mean people don't recover communities in
the social fabric has changed forever
and especially if they face more acute
disaster more recurrently which is
happening but it's hard to harder to
recover if you're if the base you're
building from is incredibly precarious
and I will also another favorite
argument of mine is one way to reduce
the precarity is to invest in our
educational system so that people can
understand the complex systems that are
compounding disadvantage and creating
harm because it's not surprising that
the increase in the meanness in the
inattention lack of care for other
people
corresponds with the divestment from
public education and so there is
something about understanding where
people are at that engenders the
compassion that you're saying is so
important we've been now toying around
with this what could possibly be more
important than having the children when
they're born into the world have deep
feelings of interconnectedness
unconditional love presence and having
children in school do things like
collectively do project-based learning
around solving the sustainable
development goals I mean if you can mix
together feelings of deep
interconnectedness with feelings of
trying to tackle the biggest challenge
that you
any faces like together it makes it so
that like all the things downstream gets
solved by that most upstream thing of
education but you also gave this really
interesting example it started making me
like want to actually like analyze where
the like where the fault is because how
do you take like billions of people that
now live in Metropolis and try and like
prescribe variables to the weight of the
of the prescribed weights to them to the
people that have the greatest amount of
influence over the sufferings that are
being catalyzed by the issues at hand
and so like I mean just I mean examples
are like like are you really trying to
reshape rules and regulations with your
wealth to try and propagate your own
advantages or are you trying to really
understand how you can contribute to the
collectives flourishing and like why not
make it more transparent if someone's
buying a fifth yacht or a tenth house or
a fifth watch or if they're investing
money into something that's destroying
the environments or indigenous peoples
lives or or reshaping rules and
regulations by hiring lobbyists like
just like some some serious consequences
need to be I mean we don't want to
inflate we're pacifists we don't want to
inflict harm on to people but some very
serious psychedelics need to be
administered into those people's lives
psychedelics would be good but one of
the questions I have my students debate
is whether corporate negligence that
leads to harm to workers or communities
if people should go to jail for that I
mean we send people to jail really
quickly for the kinds of misconduct that
poor people often get kind of caught
doing but we rarely rarely hole
corporate CEOs responsible and they make
an argument that you know how could they
have known this plant halfway around the
world in India was you know wasn't
operating at maximum I'm in the in the
case where I started my research career
which was a chemical plant disaster in
India that was owned by an American
company Union Carbide
and for literally thirty years there was
a tug of war over getting the CEO of
Union Carbide at the time held
criminally accountable in India and the
u.s. wouldn't extradited Wow
and some people said you know you can't
blame one person for the many and there
were many many things that contributed
to the disaster happening but it started
with plant design which was clearly the
responsibility of the parent company in
the US you know it had to do with not
training workers enough adn't during a
time when they were planning to shut the
plant down but whose decision was that
and so the question of where do you
locate responsibility in these complex
systems it's in many places but elites
are often protected from that
responsibility and so that that steam
didn't kill himself yeah it's so
thinking about how our system of justice
itself reproduces the lack of
accountability that produced the
injustice in the first place and I think
that some of that is the force of law
needs to be implemented not restrained
one thing that I harp on is we so often
focus on the abuses of law and there are
many at the same time there are hugely
risky and harmful activities that the
law basically doesn't touch and lets go
on unregulated and so we've got both
going on at the same time what an insane
example of like trying to like extradite
someone that is that could be viewed as
completely
at responsible was held responsible for
the death of hominid it's debated but
ten thousands a good number to work with
of death you yeah
there were at least thirty five hundred
in the twenty four hours or in the
immediate aftermath some people argue
that there were ten thousand then it was
of course hard to to keep up when you
had massive body burnings and things
which Abaco plant explosion was this
Union Carbide plan in Bhopal India and
and this is the story gets carbide plant
in Bhopal yes and the kind of it's it's
a very complicated story because it was
a plant set up to make pesticides hoping
to make India food self-sufficient so
the way trying to do things that are
good have these kind of underbelly but
even from the beginning they built the
plant with too much capacity because
they wanted to corner the market one
read that you had so much capacity and
thus the amount of chemical release when
they come when you know things went
badly was huge forty tons of toxic gas
were released in a you know in in one
night in that city there was no planning
so people didn't know how to evacuate
they they of course didn't trust public
authorities as often happens in in
disaster scenarios and what you still
see is when you see catastrophic events
like this people acting as though it's a
complete surprise we didn't see this
coming even though you've got
communities living on the fence line of
factories and it's it's really
counterintuitive to think that you
wouldn't have problems in these
facilities given that come their
technical complexity given the fact that
they're not regulated there was a pest a
small small pesticide not a pesticide a
fertilizer facility in Texas that blew
up
I believe in 2014 and in West Texas not
a complicated production facility but
really a mixing facility
when it blew up it took out essentially
the whole town a middle school across
the street that was it was after hours
so there weren't kids in this school but
in some of the aftermath reporting you
know regulator had not been on site at
that facility in like a decade yeah and
so the idea that were regulating even
when you've got really and this high
risk things being stored and in this
case it was ammonium nitrate fertilizer
which was used in the Oklahoma bombing
the Texas City disaster in the 40s that
took out Texas City it was an ammonium
nitrate fertilizer explosion so again
it's not we shouldn't be surprised when
these when these things blow and we need
to build our societies either where we
design away from the risk and one of the
really exciting areas of work is green
chemistry where you design the products
and chemical processes we need but with
chemicals where the structure of the
chemical itself is not dangerous so
you're not trying to stop things from
leaking from the plant you're trying to
design at the front end yeah and that's
really exciting the important work most
upstream is using green chemicals that
could never even cause some sort of
massive explosions and killing I
couldn't believe it when you said the
numbers were 3,500 at least in the India
exposed that bats that was mind blowing
when you said that to me because most
people don't think of drastic things
like that causing that much damage and
who's held responsible how can we
mitigate it you went to the most
upstream issue that's a great one of
green chemicals another one is like why
are people able to reshape rules and
regulations in the favors of avoiding
sentences jail sentences or you know
this is a big this is a big deal how do
you hold people that are adding zeros to
the end of their paychecks
that are causing environmental issues
and public health issues for other
people's lives in the process of adding
those zeros to their paychecks how do
you hold them completely responsible
well one of the reasons they're not held
responsible is because that whole system
is seen as kind of natural rich people
will be rich people the rich people will
have power though influence our
political system and again an important
role of a field like anthropology is we
may not have the answers like how do you
fix that but we can say it didn't have
to be like that there's a lot of
different ways to organize social life
across in different historical periods
in different geographic context and so
to denaturalize a system that's so
productive of harm is a first step and I
would say this happens at the kind of
educational moment way upstream or the
sense that kind of the way things are
just have to be and it sounds ridiculous
that any that that would really shape
what's possible in a society but it does
and and if you and I think it's more
likely that you'll naturalize the status
quo if you don't have educational spaces
where people can learn to kind of see in
the crevices see the system patterns see
comparatively and so it is it's critical
to have that kind of deliberative space
in societies yeah the hard core focus on
upstream solving the these big
challenges is crucial what was the the
the anthropology of environmental health
regarding asthma well asthma asthma
rates have skyrocketed in the last
number of decades some of that's
probably a matter of data collection and
reporting but Azzam isn't as
difficult to diagnose is something like
autism where you there's a lot of
debates over do the rising rates or is
it just because they're what they're
counting is autism is different there's
clearly been rises in autism too but as
most simple comparatively there is a lot
of different kinds of asthma but you've
got soaring rates and even in the early
90s there was often a sense it was
really treated as an in-body disease you
sort of had asthma and you took care of
the individual child rather than say how
our ambient conditions like air
pollution producing asthmatic conditions
and I think you know the World Health
Organization really started highlighting
air quality as a driver of health in the
last decade I mean because it really
dealt with infectious disease before
that and so imagine what a kind of phase
transition an organization like the
World Health Organization has to go
through to move from infectious disease
to air pollution as a driver of
morbidity yeah and more and there's more
and more health outcomes that are
connected to environmental exposures
than we knew even a decade ago diabetes
for example which was long treated as
like a dietary disease in genetic is now
they're connecting to plastics exposure
and so once you start recognizing the
environmental determinants of disease it
just complicates health care health
diagnosis insurance you know the whole
thing shakes up the environmental
determinants of disease interesting so
the World Health Organization only
recently ten years ago put air quality
index s uh I wouldn't say I don't know
when they first did it but they first
started giving real visibility to it and
have done and it's it's move the dial I
mean I think it's changed the discussion
because you know a lot of everyday
pollution was seen as just a necessary
effect of industrialization and economic
prosperity the idea that you know the
smell of pollutions the smell of money
and I think that even even now though
you have government's arguing that
pollution levels don't they push back
against the claim that they have deep
health outcomes which are
counterintuitive against the science but
there is a deep sense in some people I
think genuinely believe that economic
development is a more basic mode to
prosperity than that environmental
health is secondary to that I think
that's shifting but it's still a
challenge yeah just a big question on
that front in general is just what are
we building what are like what are we
building so many people talk about an
artificial general intelligence or like
digital super intelligence like that's
what people are talking about now that's
what we're building well it's I think
that the promise of a I likely extends
what it can do for us on the other hand
I think that the the complexity of the
problems we've been talking about are
going to be data intensive like we're
going to have to have massive
investments in data infrastructure and
data practices and data expertise in
order to have any sense not only if we
don't want to just characterize problems
we want to change them and and I'll give
you just an example that's not even
planetary and scope but it's although
it's happening all over so city
governments including Vancouver are
making decisions about whether to allow
ride-sharing the uber should uber be
allowed to come to town I was super
surprised when there was no yeah
Bluebird lifts here and there are
massive advantages particularly in some
places for example in Indian cities
ride-sharing there's a Indian company
called Ola has given an uber is there
have given women per
increase mobility that seemed safe
because you can be tracked on your phone
you don't wonder where you're going so
there's many advantages on the other
hand there's clearly many disadvantages
you displace other transportation
providers they increase in density and
vehicles in Indian cities in the same
timeframe that you had the development
of ride-sharing is impressive so there's
just vehicle density and associated air
pollution there's the fair labor for the
drivers I always talk to my lyft and
uber drivers and often it's not a good
secure way to to make a living it's
often they feel duped into it the other
kinds of transport providers get
dislocated you know so there's it's
perturbator whole city for this to
happen and city officials have the
responsibility to say we're going to let
them come or not and they might just say
no because the transportation sector is
highly organized and say no but it's
even more than that but to say how do
you assess whether this is equitably
distributed advantage to this city what
kind of data would you need and you
would need qualitative data about
transportation options and the quality
of a jaw of a certain kinds of job you
would need lots of quantitative data
about vehicle density and pollution
levels and health outcomes from that and
somehow that needs to be aggregated and
not overly determine in advance by
corporate interests that have would
benefit from a certain decision and so
just imagining that one single decision
that cities already are trying to make
it's just incredibly complicated and I
think there's you know a hundred
decisions like that that governing
officials need to make daily and so
building the the work the infrastructure
the workflows the expertise the
sensibilities of you know what's fair
and right I mean there's just a mangle
of things that happen to
that need to happen together yeah
inclusive state holding is a very
interesting one so when a new technology
gets deployed into a city can it be that
there's a social fabric and the social
contract that's actually designed where
it's not just investors and the
employees of the company that get the
most but also the workers that are doing
like a gig economy or the customers of
that service and the community that that
company is located can each gain
ownership of that flourishing because
they're all technically a part of it
there's stuff like that that's really
interesting there's also just I think
really again just going to the most
upstream issue just catalyzing feelings
of deep interconnectedness presence love
at young ages solving these big
challenges getting kids involved -
solving these big challenges like
project-based learning environments I
also think don't I mean I think it
starts there but I also think it's
really important that people in various
roles in our society a city engineer a
you know that's helping decide if you
put in a new metro line someone that
works for a corporation that you know
makes chemicals people can make a
difference by having high you know
strong analytic capabilities a really
robust ethical imagination where you
know we don't need to tell them this is
wrong this is not this is not wrong
we need people need ethical freedom but
they need to go into that with a strong
understanding of what these what the
implications of their actions are and so
the idea that you know a certain kind of
transportation option has these
cascading effects on other people both
and going forward into
intergenerationally and so you know that
line between how do you mandate
compassion is over is its you know I a
real paradox but one that I think that
we can
that are much better prepare people for
than we are now it's a it's like a
marriage of both doing it at that
grassroots as the child's born into the
world and designing the social fabric
that way but also like very top-down
like have government officials and big
owners of corporate companies to have
them also dose into these feelings of
interconnectedness and have them also
partake in that designing and
architecting of that next world I want
to ask you about your own personal
experiences with deep feelings of
interconnectedness or unity or oneness
how have you connected to those feelings
I think I have a deep sense that my role
in the world as a professional as a
researcher and teacher and just as a
citizen I'm a parent that we you have
responsibilities for people beyond your
close circle and that it's though that
we you can't you are responsible for it
all so to speak and so the the sense of
putting in a good day's work to kind of
keep the world afloat I think I was
deeply socialized towards that and and
not in a kind of politically radically
family but a sense that you you did
write to your neighbors you were mindful
of downstream consequences and so I
think it being a teacher is a good
profession because it's a slow route to
care and change but it does feel like a
route that that works that's important I
think it's a lot harder for people that
are make their living kind of in the
belly of the beast they it's harder to
find up opportunities to do good works
and so and I don't think it makes sense
to kind of blame them individually it's
like how do we produce systems where
people don't have
everyday options to exercise ethical
commitment you know in a kind of
systems-level way yeah we are all
responsible for the outcome of this
world and treating it like that's part
of all of our unique blueprints as were
birthed into the world is is this
paramount and we are responsible for
each other in this planet as stewards
and the future of the environment of it
and the next generations of it the last
question that I want to ask you is what
do you think is the most beautiful thing
Wow the most beautiful thing I think the
most beautiful thing is people having
the capacity to collectively evaluate
what's going on and to imagine and plan
together for increasing and equitably
distributed prosperity so it's not so
much that I can imagine on a world
that's otherwise but perhaps it's the
teacher in me I can imagine us doing a
better job trying to architecture that
world as you've said I love that
architecting equitably distributed
prosperity I love that let's do it that
was beautiful can thanks so much for
coming on to the show really appreciate
thank you great questions
thank you that's was super fun thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
check out the links in the bio below to
Kim's work also check out the links in
the bio below to the American
Anthropological Association support them
and support the other artists the
entrepreneurs the leaders around the
world that you believe in support them
and help them grow you can find all of
our links below to our show you can
support us on paypal patreon
cryptocurrency you can design cool merch
and get paid all those links are blow
and go and build the future
and manifest your dreams into the world
we love you very much thank you for
tuning in and we will see you soon
that's a wrap
[Music]
you
[Music]